all right welcome to video you won a war
zone final again and I'm a bit late here
just a couple of seconds into the
tournament alright so let's see what's
possible here I'm played one of those
for a couple of days it's usually the
soccer for the US crowd or football for
the European crowd on ya in the meantime
I want to Bishop c4 I didn't appreciate
now I'm trying to get the bishop here
using the long diagonal so if you place
94 should I prevent this Queen euphonium
25a me not too bad to prevent this yeah
now I can even open up the long diagonal
this looks nice yes I don't mind that so
much still cannot take and if this
diagonal evening gets opened that's very
nice alright so my nights you format be
a nuisance yeah so
maybe hmm not quite sure what to do here
94 is a bit annoying 96 to come and be
far if you might've rookie won the ass
thought this should be it should be okay
just king is happening
this seafoam move sir c4 McLean wouldn't
have a square so this is why I was
thinking so long i hope this wins I'm
only here I only have 10 seconds left
no what does she became the first game
in those tournaments are always somewhat
difficult for me to adjust to the time
and so on alright so sort of Queens
gambit accepted here already accepted
whatever need to catch up quickly now
losing the first game is always really
terrible in those tournaments this looks
nice though t5 already threatened yeah
II five is good t5 is also good how to
learn to choose this is the reason why
this was also good very nice Queen
position now
how to see how would untangle this
position 95 queen f6e mmm so maybe just
here
yeah it's not completely winning but
still very nice possibly I could have
done something better looked like it it
should win outright but somehow it
doesn't
so maybe I can even keep the Queen's on
plane 96 here nine to six ER
not Queen h5 tweenage 5g six green tags
that's not winning at least I didn't see
it now this is nice now both be 787s
attacked cannot take because of the pin
and he needs the Queen to protect you
seven so this should win now yeah yeah
he doesn't have a move really oh this
one maybe just g6 I Queen edge 500 okay
come on take it should also be enough
really aged 7 hanging
yeah not very clever this check really
good okay but I'm just winning also
technically so no big deal could have
been quicker maybe
yeah this way i'm already down a couple
of points why didn't i get void it again
just one point no idea doesn't make much
sense alright so it doesn't help just
continue yeah why just develops you
shouldn't be too too threatening really
taking the bishop and then then here to
again to take this bishop so now i have
the two bishops which is nice good Queen
on f6 you have to look like a very
comfortable position Knight to f4 yeah
93 possible Bishop g4 also black already
looks a very good here the special bond
c5 is especially strong okay threatening
night age three year
this is possible really
and not one hundred percent sure that
this is really winning but it looks it
looks oyster various very dangerous
needs to get here and then i sacrifice
Ian Ruby for this looks dangerous at
least I'm on this 90m rook e8 could be a
good move maybe I'm also simply tear
threatening to take get the King out to
e3 yeah but just rupee eight right how
does the cavity three now don't see it
yeah this should be should be winning
really no way to cover he three and he's
also lots lots of time down him
animals yeah well stuff like this okay
so okay this is even I mean it's not
great but you can you can continue a
couple of moves you for 10 as a better
we take I've got c4 check coming up okay
material wise he had quite something for
the queen but time position button
recently okay yeah Kings Indian I would
like to play this h3 line very often
people don't have a good recipe against
this
c6
yeah i think i can i can try to install
some p75 or provoke your weaknesses like
this here black is so this has just
weakened himself without any obvious
compensation g5g five all right who
wants to get the night to do six which
is understandable
and so do play this may be queen bee
three queen bee three to a three they
might have not a five though FFG form
hmm
yeah okay it's not great on edge too but
I didn't have so much choice so he's
some his weekend quite a lot here
yeah I'm time Tom terribly slow in this
game
yeah I don't think the position is a
problem but i'm down to 30 seconds so
need to hurry up here the ante is left
with this crappy bishop and the weakness
only five only possible counter place a
move like Raquel for put young I don't
think it's working
yeah time time is a problem sorry cannot
take on d5 well it does anyway so now
I'm just winning the look
okay right we this was important okay
and let's try to catch up here oh this
guy's pretty much ahead of me trying
some complicated setup here maybe going
for some quick a wind possible uh-huh
okay here maybe this is good c7 can be
weakness for me but it sounds a question
what what this Bishop is doing okay very
interesting so how should I continue
here this is debatable okay it didn't
take I was more concerned about taking
on a six now I can get this night to see
five I didn't see that she's having a
saying but maybe it's not so bad yeah
interesting position if I again can get
rid of all the heavy pieces I mean I'm
absolutely okay but the question is if
I'm able to do that doesn't look so bad
though that I want it might be here
actually manage let's go here hard for
him to avoid the Queen's right now
after the Queen trade I really should be
good okay avoided it but now I've got
the g fall and quite quite a nice
position he's got all the weaknesses
don't mind before really I can just take
and get their Knight to f6 it's also
good good place for this piece so what's
this I can just capture right take you
for now is that some don't see what
what's the problem I can take it the
young 25 now and not sure what's best
here could you find maybe ok so now I'm
a couple of points up and his position
is totally rectory hmm this was to
quickly play chamber me it's still nice
but I could have done something better
pretty sure
yeah it's still enough though I could've
just taken the Queen but this should
should also run oops not the best play
ever but it was enough so what's
happening here I'm place 12 or something
this guy's got 42 with ridiculous they
made some mostly more so I wanted to
play c4 of course not see three okay
let's play some crazy game at hope the
tea and that he falters
yeah no no this is it's really weird and
maybe not too good we had two stated to
mega mall slip on move to we are let's
just totally unnecessary
yeah I know it's a it's crazy and
probably just crap but if trying to
annoy him here and take care of takes
there okay who should I have some
chances yet I mean the gphone isn't this
stuff isn't this something I could like
take G for huntin who not much choice to
take him
pretty unsure about this how to
understand this position maybe mmm yeah
I most likely we get we get ever get a
two I wants to double I can take c3 now
so this too late but I had no
alternative I can just take crap oh man
this was terrible from move to
place 22 is really well took less than
great
and what's this now ok ok so maybe try
to get something going here place 22
really feels like last place somehow
yeah this kind of stuff is just not
working for white so let's let's try
this year threatened Bishop g4 winning
the Queen maybe it's working the baton
and yeah it is working so maybe a quick
win here okay so 27 mmm really need need
a huge run now I got kingscrusher now
draw this time I need to win every game
okay I'm exchange the the bishop always
like to do that it's um about blacks
best p so let's get rid of this piece
okay now I'd like to play on fyd five if
possible you might go is 60 e5 himself
as possible okay so now take and
therefore should still be quite good for
me if this you five idea our stuff like
this which easily can provoke weaknesses
queen age for to come and then e5
possibly on d5 if you place if I've
himself a player 5 yeah no I've got a
weakness on g6 to play against alrighty
five
hmm
this looks like a good position a move
get rid of the bishop and then if he
takes 90 x i have d 6 as a nice square
for the night okay i can take it here
then d 6 is a huge huge fork on all
heavy pieces so which which one this one
yeah let's check so he needs to take
here now maybe you six already come only
six it looks like the most aggressive
way to press this h6 now hanging yeah
this one's the house
two exchanges up so should a sec now or
queen f5 maybe just Queen a five there's
no threat right can take here it's not
even a check okay all right and so it's
always a question if you should maybe
draw against the more dangerous players
but usually like to simply play so 28
points this guy has not too bad yeah
it's I need to just win lots of games
very quickly so so now just to develop
or g5 like g5 could be I don't know I
need to be a big week here cannot think
all day
hmm
not sure what this move was doing I mean
yeah hard for me to do anything else
just kind of French exchange with
nothing much happening maybe deform here
am Bishop f5 his guts out okay I need to
cover it still be to us hanging so okay
so see 5c five maybe c5 takes d4 this
winning material not quite sure can I
need to set him some problems here yeah
of course just retreats and just doing
nothing basically I know if I check here
and what now what now how to get a draw
with the piece downer I think we need to
now
now i can i can take this any time so
don't need to rush this is just made em
I'm ft 6 m okay all you need to retreat
enter it's also just winning okay i see
it's not that simple I don't want to
exchange Queens yet yeah come on wants
to draw gotta love those people and just
playing what whatever but why should I
take a draw I'm just a piece up here
yeah this is made is offering a drawer
right okay so place 11 now catching up a
bit but first places are difficult i
just played 22 badly in the beginning of
this this tournament so maybe here i can
get something with some aggressive
aggressive moves okay the edge porn I'm
not quite sure what it's doing but looks
aggressive what he did there okay I
don't mind that you lose the spawn I
just want quick development here some
should see form it's not playable you to
cover this first I mean I still see the
issue that i'm not sure what where is
king should go and have pretty pretty
nice compensation for this pawn light
squares are very nice
doesn't hurt to to get in a really
simple threat once in a while ok so
maybe Queenie form you can play c4 maybe
okay Queenie phone oh this is check
unfortunately so it's no mate ok
interesting way to defend this want to
play root G form look at you for now you
cannot take tweenage 7mate end and I've
got Luke g1 next move this is quite a
lot here on the king so
then no immediate win it's hard to
believe don't see one I might give me a
kind of play at five okay come on let's
say five this one's peace at least ok
very surprising stuff here now I can
take g6 also okay
ooh k h6 could be major sin that
possible he's just playing on time and I
just need to play quicker it's just
playing random crab and tries to win on
time as usual yeah maybe you'll even
manage because I I only converted into
this winning end game which is difficult
with 20 seconds on the clock this is
quite slow though yeah whatever it was
totally winning anyway I mean before not
not not really a great tournament air
quality wise alright so some Italian
game here
let's try try to get something quickly
here and some not not so easy to refute
I hope it looks a very shaky but for
black I mean so but ok maybe maybe this
is service this is feasible so maybe
this year just Bishop f3 push up a three
threatened oh he ignores it basically ok
so quindi 727 283 looks dangerous at
least you know Queen h5 now this should
be winning now when i try to h1 now ok
i'm catching up a bit but place first
seems out of reach I mean would be
deserved anyway I'm just playing badly
or too slow whatever everything so on
this is not the way you should play the
two nights tango white is a couple of
extra moves on a normal position quite a
huge space advantage everywhere so
should be should be quite nice for white
yeah until some is losing a piece now
just do we had set up so one apiece and
I want to get rid of this Bishop there
so that I can castle actually yeah okay
you might try something like against
five years so maybe this can prevent
this and not just castles I mean it's
still it's rather safe here I hope you
can get a night to g3
yeah of course is some trying to to do
something here still what still it's
hard to believe so now I've got the edge
file and I hope I can do something with
it it's often not so easy to to really
get something concrete going again does
this kind of VN chatter position where
you don't have have a bishop so here
maybe go in to go into g-form 348
threatens made at least you're close to
made it's not so easy to prevent
actually threatening Quincy 7 now and
down as i can just take and this is over
yeah 27 rogue sm so I'm catching up a
bit here yeah I'm always astonished that
how many people play those completely
crap gambits which basically just just
loose material for nothing I'll give you
just a bad position whatever yeah
funny enough just yesterday i did a
video on this this it's just bad for
white of course it's tricky em you can
you can play all this stuff i'd hope
that your opponent yeah makes mistakes
and doesn't know the theory and whatever
but usually you just worse alright so
here gaining more time and Queen f6 to
attack f3 yeah i mean the gphone have
the gphone with Luke on g ade so
shouldn't be too bad so I play this here
we're taking this Bishop and also
threatening on light attics H tomb
simply so night XH toward this says
something better even okay can night x
h2 is not does not okay okay so let's
grab this shouldn't be a bad as well
hmm got him I just hate those draw furs
completely completely nonsense okay
night 95 so f 3 here it's maybe not so
clear you and yeah just something that
something went wrong there obviously
mm-hmm besides the fact that I'm too
slow as usual
rookie 1 f 2 would be nice especially
considering the time yeah now it's an
it's running again but down well the
time this helped a bit f1 cannot prove
be prevented I think yeah all right
place five somewhat creeping slower to
the top places it so all right maybe
still some slight chances despite my
somewhat shaky play here
right the h3 system okay I usually try
to okay forget about it pre went f5 was
what I was intending to say but I played
it anyway it's not very good but he
played it anyway now maybe it is not so
so bad but hmm alright
difficult usually this is this f5 in
this kind of position is a problem for
black because i get to get the
foursquare and the g file and whatever
pretty obvious but sometimes it's so
playable and maybe here here it is ok
root g 5 is got queena for you ok if I
play Queen g6 what is he doing then ok
good rook f6 so maybe I need to get out
of this here I was surprised how quickly
sometimes people go for a super
dangerous stuff and just well whatever
i'm gonna just take you I don't
understand anything here so was just
hanging wasn't it
not only crazy what's happening here ok
so now take g5 maybe as usual down long
time quite quite a lot here
trying to meet you of course
Wow it was two seconds on the clock all
right Wow getting very high rated
opponents all the time I mean I already
gained like 40 rating points or 30 or
whatever in this tournament now I
accidentally played this this line which
I don't usually play Bishop c5 and it
already looks looks a bit a bit like I
don't want this position okay but taking
on your six also mates made a weird
impression don't understand this at all
okay so let's now look slow just like
like okay for me I hope I don't know
what is doing here well I will just
attack him
the idea to play h4 h4 now I have to
look sir I take F to what's what's
what's this I can also take here in
everything winds can take him this looks
looks quite simple okay can play king h1
I didn't really consider this okay so
let's just cancel him
threatening made on gage Dungey too okay
wanting to tell you I didn't smell what
a mess I didn't yeah whatever just awful
I mean this was winning but every move
every move one besides the one what I
played most probably okay well maybe
maybe I can still fight a bit here I
mean you see he's played this really
what
still quite some chances here
should have done this before would have
been better even there's some pinned now
I'm pinned really under leave an
unbelievable game I mean to lose this is
really heartbreaking he placed the worst
all right tough tournament I'm making it
tough on myself
right him he resigned at the end of
course no draw don't understand ray now
I know someone a bit annoyed to take
with lots of things I mean people just
offer draw and then then lambda to a
lost position in five moves so why
should I take a draw at any point
yeah this is some very nice of course
extra pawn I've got a nice night on on
f5 and he's got pretty much nothing but
holds so hmm okay grab here grab that
for like two pawns up and I get the C
file nice job with the rook now okay
this was too quick a pre move really so
here whatever everything winds basically
a bunch of pawns are bent don't see any
huge technical issues this is gone also
all right maybe place three or something
55 minutes left okay some super quick
resign us might help
oh yeah I know I know I just wanted to
try sometimes this kind of stuff is
really working ok it's not like I'm in a
terrible position now so maybe I
could've could afford that in a wave
okay so what's going on here I just
blundered b7 ok I guess he won't take it
now it didn't take it to move before AHA
wants to get rid of its of the Queen's
stopping d for now so the five year ok
let's protect this and I'll try to open
the F file or some other lines I don't
mind I just want to open it up to get to
his King
okay no mate ok but
now he cannot take taking would loose
but you can just drop back to d2 this
might might be enough for a draw what is
your thinking about not sure just ripped
it to
we're disconnected or no idea what is
doing or is it a matter of time now no
idea what he's doing just ripped it too
and it's a drone I mean you can try a
six or something drop the rope bag a six
and so on but it's it shouldn't be
should should be nothing don't ask me
what what was happening there third
place now maybe now a super quick win
for place too
come on night xe5
now I doubt that this would be quick
enough if I get something here at all so
I'm questionable
trying to get the Bishop to d3 I mean I
just I just need a quick mate it doesn't
matter if it is he a corrector or
whatever just quickly to his King now
this won't won't work out quite shorts a
matter of seconds here oh no it's almost
it's completed already so so place three
I guess yeah first place I really play
terrible and sorry for maybe some bad
words I wasn't too satisfied here with
my Play so I'm third place at the end
and some strange stuff happened at the
top standing west's Qaeda's guy he was
leading all the way through and now some
other people are I had here alright yeah
well thanks for watching anyway I hope
you enjoyed it I'm just seeing I really
had my father the the highest average
here now I still I said I lost quite
quite a lot alright yeah thanks for
watching talk to you soon with a new
video am I